so you've heard in the morning a lot of
the epidemiology about this you've heard
the national and local data you've heard
about what's been happening and in
Connecticut you've heard some really
really interesting innovative ideas of
what can be done through technology and
online and now you're going to hear more
about specific effective behavioral
interventions for men who have sex with
men game and bisexual men the way this
is set up first Gina D'Angelo from the
Department of Public Health is going to
talk about selecting effective
behavioral interventions and then she
will provide a little bit of an overview
for each of the interventions that we're
going to be talking about from a
theoretical perspective the core
elements of that intervention sort of
some of the science behind the
intervention and then you're going to
hear from people who have experience on
the ground level implementing these
interventions so on that note welcome
Gina D'Angelo
and I'm short so the mic goes down okay
so on that note we are going to spend
the majority of this afternoon really
starting to look at what some of these
effective interventions are but prior to
doing that into delving into the
specific interventions we wanted to give
you some things to think about
especially for people out there who are
doing the work with MSM to think about
well how do you even go about choosing
or selecting an intervention that is
right for you and so we are specifically
talking about selecting for men who have
sex with men but it does apply to all
the other populations that you work with
as well so just for anyone in the room
who is not fully up on what behavioral
interventions are you know we're talking
about interventions are intervening in
such a way that we're looking at
changing people's behavior and the
intervention is the way that they do
that is they actually try to influence
behavioral determinants and a behavioral
determinant is something that actually
makes people act or behave in the way
that they do and a lot of times the
interventions are trying to change
people's knowledge sometimes it's their
attitudes sometimes it's the skills that
they have around protecting themselves
or not protecting themselves and so
those are the things that we're trying
to effect change on the CDC has
identified 69 effective behavioral
interventions and what that means is
they've been rigorously studied through
research and have been proven effective
at changing behavior and if you look at
the actual research studies they've
really a change of behavior
significantly we're talking about
significant decreases in risky behavior
we're talking about significant
increases in condom use and all they
have to show all positive outcomes in
order to be considered effective so
those are the abbeys the effective
behavioral interventions we call them
dearly of ease and then a lot of you may
have heard about debbie and basically
debbie that's just a term for diffusing
or getting the interventions out into
the community so CDC created something
called the Debbie project they took 26
of their 69 interventions and stuck them
in the W project
and what the Debbie project did was they
just packaged him into user friendly
kits that organizations like you know
some of you that are here today could
just take and implement really easily
and they also come with training and
with capacity building and technical
assistance for people who want to use
them as well so choosing an epi or a
Debbie which best matches not only your
community but your agency is more likely
to be effective in the real world and to
work it affecting behavior change so how
do we go about selecting an intervention
really we would like people to think
about answering two questions the first
is this the best intervention for my
target population and the second is does
your agency or yourself have the
resources to not only implement the
intervention but to maintain it over
time so how do we get those answers well
there are five simple steps to selecting
an intervention the first being a
community assessment and I'm going to
talk about that in a minute because
there's lots of different community
assessments there's large scale they're
small scales so what are we really
talking about what do you have to do
when you're looking to select an
intervention choosing your target
population and your risk behavior you
know in this case we're talking about
gay men and other men who have sex with
men today but whatever your target
population is examining the
interventions for the chosen population
and really getting to know what they are
what makes them tick to have a good
understanding as to whether or not you
can do them and that leads into your
assessing your own capacity which is
your ability to be able to actually do
them and then selecting a matching
intervention which means you want to
have a good fit between does the
intervention work for the community and
does it work for our agency so if we go
back to step one that community
assessment process you're really looking
at assessing the community's HIV
prevention needs through observations
and interviews very minor data
collection which pretty much means you
know look at the data that your
surveillance you know the DPH
surveillance already has look at some
data and information that's been
collected through your community
planning groups needs assessments that's
the kind of data that you could use to
backup your case but what we're really
looking at when
talk about community assessment to
select an intervention is get to know
the community get out of your office go
out to where people are now when we're
talking about gay men and men who have
sex with men we're talking about the
book stores here in Connecticut and let
me just tell you I had the most
eye-opening experience of my life going
to an adult bookstore at twelve o'clock
noon on a work day one of the best
trainings I ever went to was for an
intervention called community promise
and my colleagues are probably really
sticky here in the story but it really
impacted me after having worked in this
field for so long to be thrust into this
situation where you're forced to look
and see what's going on I mean at this
adult bookstore there were men of every
race age social status going in and out
of there like a revolving door and
another place that they send us which
was really interesting was Bushnell Park
in Hartford and you would think god what
are you going to look and see happening
there oh my god you know we had
conversations with the garbage men about
where they were picking up the condoms
the vendors that sell food talk to him
they could tell you when the cars come
around pick up the young men and when
they drop them back off so there's so
much you can learn by just going out and
putting your finger on the pulse of a
community so you got to find out what's
the population but not just the
population what's the subpopulation you
know there's a lot of diversity within a
group of gay men or a group of em men
who have sex with men so you might be
looking at men who have sex with men
that are young black MSM so you have to
really think about who's out there what
are they doing that's putting them at
risk what are those specific risk
behaviors that you want to change and
what are their specific needs so I kind
of went over some of this but community
assessment means going out to those bars
cruising areas parties bookstores
mapping out the activity they actually
had a straw a picture when we went of
the park and like put on there what we
were seeing and when things were
happening finding out about the activity
where it's happening and when and how
interviewing people that see the
activity like
those garbage men and those vendors but
also interviewing people who work with
them so that means collaborating with
other folks that see the same people and
talking to people who are a member of
the community itself so it's all an
effort to get closer to that core group
what community assessment in this sense
of the word does not really mean is you
don't have to do a lot of data
collection you don't have to conduct a
big old needs assessment you don't have
to spend a lot of time money or
resources just to go out and try to get
do some good information gathering about
your target population so step 2 based
on whatever you find out in that
community assessment is to choose your
population and your behavior to target
what is the main target population the
subpopulation who in what behavior are
you specifically looking to target the
guy went through all that so once you
know the pop and the the target the risk
behavior you really need to start
examining the interventions and for a
good fit which ones specifically target
your populations are very geared for
specific things and there's information
on the eby's on the CDC website one page
fact sheets that you can assess and
there's information on the Debbie's at
effective interventions org and pretty
comprehensive stuff so once you've
chosen the ebi then you need to say hey
can our agency really do this and start
looking at your capacity and what
capacity really means is you know do we
have the ability do we have the right
staff this is such a key thing you have
to have a staff person that has the
ability to go out and socially reach the
people that you need them to reach do
they have the right expertise you know
funding a lot of times we hear from
people is an issue we've got funding
please apply for it people are not
applying to do work with this population
in Connecticut for some reason we need
people to apply materials can you get
ahold of them there's some of the eby's
that online when you look at it it says
the materials aren't really available
you got to make sure that you get it you
can get them or you may have to call
somebody to get them and then finally
does the agency have the ability to not
only implement but as I said sustain the
intervention over time the
great thing about the W website is they
have agency readiness tools so you could
kind of do like a self quiz and find out
if your agency is actually has what it
takes to implement and then you're going
to select your intervention based on the
community assessment the assessment of
your own agency what's the best fit here
and then go ahead and create that
detailed implementation plan and propose
an intervention and then prepare your
agency to implement and maintain it over
time so interventions on the community
basically we're looking for
organizations to propose working with
the population but take everything into
account take into account the data from
your Surveillance Unit take into account
the priority populations from your
planning group identified the
populations that you want to reach and
but also be prepared to demonstrate the
need for them to have the service and
don't forget that you should really
think about doing an updated community
type assessment on an ongoing basis with
all your populations because things
change and people don't always stay
where they were before people don't
always act the same way they did before
dph is role we put out a request for
proposals every three years for
prevention services and we do base that
on the Community Planning Group
recommendations of what populations and
what interventions should be looked at
we do support the use of evidence-based
interventions for all populations
including MSM and gay men we have staff
that are assigned as intervention
specialists to oversee each intervention
that we fund and then they can also
identify capacity-building assistance
needs for people and training needs so
our future goals continue to fund
appropriate science-based prevention
interventions for all of our populations
including MSM a lot of people for years
have said why why we only do w zebys
well number one that's what CDC pays us
to do but number two they're
cost-effective the extensive research on
them has already been done so they're
easy to replicate they're easy to
monitor and they've you know been
researched and to be culturally
appropriate which is really important
and then we need to ensure that target
populations
identified our a high priority ensure
that our chosen interventions are those
that will have the greatest impact
because resources are scarce and we need
to make sure most importantly I think
that there are more interventions
available for MSM and gay men within the
state of Connecticut ok so our immediate
next steps is our community planning
group is right now in the priority
setting process to rank part target
populations in need of prevention
services dph will be going out sometime
around the fall of 2010 for prevention
services and then we'll be hoping to
have more organizations responding there
are your effective interventions org
websites and your dph website if you
want to know what's funded now